- [Voiceover] The scatterplot drawn above,
we'll take a look at it
after we finish reading the question,
depicts the average annual
United States per capita
consumption of high fructose corn syrup
between the years 1970 and 1985.
Which of the following functions
best describes the relationship shown?
So, when we look at the scatterplot,
we see that it definitely
looks like we could fit a,
we could fit a parabola to it.
We could find a curve of best fit.
And that parabola might
look something like,
might look something like,
might look something like this.
Again, I'm just kind of estimating it,
trying to draw a parabola with my hand.
It's gonna be a hand-drawn parabola.
But it's gonna look something like that.
And what they're saying is look,
they've given us some candidates,
some quadratic functions
that would describe
this curve of best fit, or
this parabola of best fit.
And so, which of these could it be?
We'll there's a couple things
that you might immediately see.
The first is, is that a
couple of these choices
have a positive coefficient
on the highest degree term,
or the second degree term.
And then the other ones, the
other ones have a negative,
negative coefficient on
the highest degree term.
Well, if you have a positive coefficient
on the highest degree term,
or the second degree term,
and if we're talking about a quadratic,
you're going to have an
upward-opening parabola.
And if you had a negative coefficient,
it would be a downward-opening parabola.
And what we have here
is clearly it looks like
the right half of an
upward-opening parabola.
So we could rule out the ones
that would be downward-opening.
So we could rule out the ones that have
a negative coefficient
on the second degree,
second degree term.
So let's rule those out right over here.
And then when we look
at the remaining two,
we see there's a fairly
dramatic difference in them.
They have, you know,
this is 201 versus .201.
264 versus .264,
969 versus .969.
And so, we could really look
at our curve right over here
and get a sense of, and test some points.
So, if we look at, maybe
the easiest one is actually
test when x is equal to zero.
So, when x is equal to zero,
depending on how we draw our curve,
our y is going to be pretty low.
Our y is going to be close to zero.
I'll just write close
close, is going to be close to zero.
It's going to be definitely,
it's going to definitely be below five.
It's going to be probably
definitely below two.
So, let's see which of
these choices describe that.
So when x is zero here,
this term goes away,
and we're left with 0.969.
So y would be,
so this has a .0, 0.969 on it.
Which seems pretty close to our criteria,
that hey we want, when x is
zero, y is pretty close to zero.
Let's see this one.
This choice right over
here, when x is zero,
this term goes away, this term goes away,
y is 969.
So here, in order, if you pick that,
if you picked this choice right over,
this is not close to zero.
This is nowhere, this actually
would be off the charts
right over here, the .0969.
It wouldn't even fit on that graph.
So you can definitely,
you can definitely rule this one out.
And we would be left with
that choice right there.
And you could try other points,
but that one would definitely
be the easiest to evaluate.